I was home-schooled I didn't really feel  like I was part of any group so this is  a really a big one I feel like I was  born questioning everything about  reality feeling lost and alone and  always worried that I was deeply  unlovable and watching your movies - all  of my stag members made me feel less  alone for a movie like this to be  responding so well with so many  different types of people all over the  world shows that these things that I  thought were my darkness that were my  own struggles that were only mine or  actually everybody is and that makes me  feel so relieved and so happy to be a  human yeah I think that the Globes and  here you thank your boyfriend and said  that he's been such a support for you  how is he how does he help support you  oh man I mean he sees the other half of  the equation how can you explain support  I mean it goes beyond anything he's he's  just my person he's my best friend you  see her mouth I love you too when you  yeah yeah we love each other